leaving things to your kids doesn't
benefit them for a variety of reason the
average person gets inheritance in their
late 60s because their parents die in
their late 80s when that happens they
already are old and don't need the money
so if you are going to give your stuff
to your kids you should give it to them
when people deem it the most impactful
in their lives which is between 24 and
35 because that is where you can
materially change someone's living
conditions the education that they can
provide to their kids whether they can
have child care those are huge changes
in someone's life when they're in their
60s their die is more or less cast and
so if you're going to leave it to him
leave it to him one a time it's
impactful